the greatest of all time against the
greatest
of this time it is all led
to this super bowl viewers heard the
sweet voice of brad pitt narrating that
pre-kick video brad also on the mind of
fellow football fan matthew mcconaughey
yeah
i mean matthew was worried about brad
like all kansas city fans today we're
worried about you know kevin fraser
okay i'm just checking in anyway matthew
posted this fun flashback of him and
brad
in new orleans back in 2014 tossing the
football back and forth
across their balcony yeah and speaking
of matthew or flatmat
if you saw his super bowl commercial he
was one of a long list of stars who
popped up in game day ads
some we expected and others that took us
totally by surprise
[Music]
we're gonna crush those losers crush
them
i hope you got a chin strap for that wig
i'm gonna knock the taste out your mouth
feeling good like i should
win lake um oh my god hilarious
right i mean no gwen
rocks zebra print and blake a pair of
spurs as we get to see
the real story behind their hookup
thanks to matchmaker adam levine and
some
bad cell service the commercial reunited
the trio after adam left the voice
almost two years ago i'm sick of l.a
guys
i want someone completely country
uncultured
and threatened by a strong confident
woman was its wings and natto
i have you guys drake from state farm
yeah
that's drake social media was in shock
when the 34 year old rapper made a
surprise cameo as a stand-in
throwing it back to his old days on
degrassi
like a good neighborhood stand-ins don't
have lines
oh okay the star-studded ad also
featured aaron rodgers chief superfan
paul rudd
and the team's quarterback patrick
mahomes have you seen
mine it's like looking in a mirror right
i'm your fairy godmayo and that is a hot
mess
i hope it's not on during our son's nap
this will be the first time he's seen
me on tv amy schumer's 21 month old son
gene was wide awake and mesmerized
watching his mama
he doesn't say any words but he has a
lot of conviction
alexa turn on the sprinklers
honey i already ran the sprinklers lori
harvey's heart-eyed emojis were pretty
much
all of us watching her man of a few
months michael b jordan
take off his shirt alexa
[Music]
michael turns 34 tomorrow his plans to
celebrate
i got to ask my girlfriend she might
have something planned for me
cardi b channeled wayne's world stars
mike myers and dana carvey and we found
out the unlikely trio had a blast on set
she was lovely and so funny and so
beautiful
and came to play she made me laugh a lot
another 90s throwback edgar you're gonna
be late
winona ryder reprises her role from the
cult classic edward scissorhands
timothy chalamet is edward's son and the
25 year old says growing up
he adored the film edgar
we need the middle as for the most rare
celeb appearance in a super bowl ad
that goes to the boss 71 year old bruce
springsteen who's
never appeared in a commercial ever jeep
had been asking him for 10 years but
bruce kept saying no
so why did he finally agree well he
wanted to urge americans
to unite there's hope
on the road up ahead well
someone who's no stranger to super bowl
spots
rocking the same shirt he did two
decades ago
cedric the entertainer returned as one
of the bud light legends
how was it working with post malone we
had a blast on set